CORRESPONDENT ELIZABETH COHEN
HAS.
>> Reporter: WHAT PRINCESS ARE
YOU TODAY?
CINDERELLA.
JULIANNA SNOW HAS A
NEUROMUSCULAR DISEASE THAT IS
SLOWLY TAKING HER LIFE.
SHE CAN'T WALK OR BREATHE ON HER
OWN OR EVEN USE HER HANDS TO
PLAY WITH GLITTER.
>> THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS TOO
MUCH, OKAY.
>> Reporter: THE NEXT TIME
JULIANA GETS A COLD OR ANY
INFECTION HER BODY WILL BE TOO
WEAK TO FIGHT IT OFF.
WHAT DO THE DOCTORS TELL YOU IS
LIKELY TO HAPPEN IF SHE WERE TO
GET ANOTHER COLD?
>> SHE WILL MOST LIKELY DIE IF
SHE GETS ANOTHER COLD.
>> Reporter: JULIANA'S DOCTORS
PRESENTED HER PARENTS STEVE SNOW
AND MICHELLE MOON WITH TWO
DEVASTATING OPTIONS.
JULIANA COULD DIE AT HOME IN HER
PINK PRINCESS ROOM MADE
COMFORTABLE SURROUNDED BY FAMILY
OR GO TO THE HOSPITAL WHERE
TREATMENT LIKELY COULDN'T SAVE
HER OR EVEN IF IT DID, SHE WOULD
LIKELY HAVE A TERRIBLE QUALITY
OF LIFE.
>> EVERYONE TOLD US THERE IS NO
RIGHT ANSWER.
>> Reporter: SO MICHELLE AND
STEVE ASKED JULIANA SOMETHING
ALMOST NO PARENT COULD EVEN
FATHOM.
WHEN SHE WAS JUST 4 YEARS OLD,
THEY ASKED HER WHAT SHE WANTED
TO DO.
GO TO THE HOSPITAL OR GO TO
HEAVEN.
YOU BLOGGED ABOUT IT.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ME, JULIANA, IF YOU GET SICK
AGAIN, DO YOU WANT TO GO TO
HOSPITAL OR STAY HOME.
NOT THE HOSPITAL.
ME, EVEN IF THAT MEANS YOU GO TO
HEAVEN IF YOU STAY HOME?
JULIANA, YES.
ME, AND YOU KNOW THAT MOMMY AND
DADDY WON'T COME WITH YOU RIGHT
AWAY.
JULIANA, DON'T WORRY, GOD WILL
TAKE CARE OF ME.
ME, AND IF YOU GO THE HOSPITAL,
IT MAY HELP YOU GET BETTER AND
LET YOU COME HOME AGAIN AND
SPEND MORE TIME WITH US.
I NEED TO MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND THAT.
HOSPITAL MAY LET YOU HAVE MORE
TIME WITH MOMMY AND DADDY.
JULIANA, I UNDERSTAND.
>> Reporter: JULIANA TOLD HER
PARENTS SHE HATED THE HOSPITAL,
ESPECIALLY A PROCEDURE CALLED
SUCTIONING.
>> THEY STICK A TUBE ON A
SUCTION MACHINE AND STICK IT UP
THE NOSE AND DOWN PAST THE
TONGUE AND BACK INTO THE THROAT
AS DEEP AS YOU CAN GO AND YOU
START SUCTIONING.
IF GIVE ON THE CHOICE OF ME OR
ONE OF THE OTHER RESPIRATORY
TECHS SHE WOULD ASK FOR ME TO DO
IT.
>> Reporter: WAS THAT HARD TO
DO?
>> YEAH.
>> Reporter: COULD YOU WATCH HER
GO THROUGH THAT AGAIN, DO YOU
THINK?
>> IF I HAD TO.
>> Reporter: WOULD IT SAVE HER
LIFE IF SHE WERE TO GET AN
INFECTION?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
>> Reporter: MICHELLE AND STEVE
SAYS WHEN THE TIME COMES THEY'LL
HONOR THEIR DAUGHTER'S WISHES.
SOME PARENTS WOULD NOT HAVE
CONSULTED A CHILD SO YOUNG.
SO, YOU ASKED YOUR DAUGHTER AT
THE AGE OF 4 WHAT DO YOU THINK?
WHAT SHOULD WE DO?
>> SHE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT THAT
WAS.
SHE WAS AWAKE FOR EVERY SINGLE
ONE.
SHE KNOWS WHAT THAT IS.
SO, I THINK SHE HAS A RIGHT.
I THINK SHE HAS A SAY.
>> Reporter: JULIANA'S DOCTORS
TOLD CNN SHE'S AN EXCEPTIONALLY
WISE 5-YEAR-OLD AND THEY SUPPORT
HER PARENTS' DECISION TO CARRY
OUT HER WISHES.
FOR NOW, JULIANA IS ENJOYING HER
LIFE WITH HER PARENTS, HER BIG
BROTHER, ALEX.
♪ LET IT GO
CAN'T HOLD IT BACK ANY MORE ♪
♪ LET IT GO ♪
>> Reporter: AND HER PRINCES.
.
>> HER ELSA AND ANNA.
ARE THEY COUSINS?
>> THEY'RE SISTERS.
>> IT'S ANNA.
>> Reporter: I SAID ANNA.
I'M SORRY.
>> SHE FORGIVES YOU.
%-p!
REALISTIC HOPES FOR HER FOR THE
REST OF THE TIME SHE HAS LEFT?
>> FEEL LOVED.
>> Reporter: WHAT HAS GOTTEN YOU
THROUGH IT?
>> FAITH.
WHEREVER YOU MAY BE, I CAN
GUARANTEE FOR CERTAIN GOD
LISTENS TO YOU AND ME.
THE FACT THAT SHE WILL BE IN A
BETTER PLACE WHEN HER TIME
COMES.
AND WE CAN GO JOIN HER SOME DAY
AND THIS WILL ALL PASS AWAY.
>> WHAT DO YOU WANT PEOPLE TO
REMEMBER ABOUT JULIANNA?
>> HER HEART.
SHE IS JUST SO MUCH LOVE.
SO MUCH LOVE.
>> SO DSAD.
ELIZABETH JOINS US NOW.
JULIANNA TALKED ABOUT WHAT SHE
THINKS HEAVEN WILL BE LIKE?
>> HER MOTHER HAD A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT, ANDERSON.
HER MOTHER SAYS WHAT THEY
DISCUSSED IN HEAVEN SHE WON'T BE
IN A WHEELCHAIR AND SHE'LL BE
ABLE TO RUN AROUND OUTSIDE AND
PLAY AND SHE'LL BE ABLE TO EAT.
NONE OF WHICH SHE CAN DO RIGHT
NOW.
>> AND HER DOCTORS ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PARENTS'
DECISION?
>> THEY ARE.
I INTERVIEWED SEVERAL OF HER
DOCTORS AND NURSES AND ALL OF
THEM WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE
CHOICE THAT HER PARENTS HAVE
MADE.
I WANT TO READ YOU ACTUALLY TWO
OF THEM.
HER NURSE IN THE INTENSIVE CARE
UNIT WHO WAS WITH HER OVER
SEVERAL HOSPITAL STAYS SAYS
THERE IS NO CURE FOR HER AND I
WANT HER LIVING AND HER DYING IN
HER PRINCESS ROOM AT HOME
SURROUNDED BY HER FAMILY AND NOT
BY THE COLD TECHNOLOGY OF THE
HOSPITAL.
THEN HER PULMONOLOGY DR. DANNY
SHAW TOLD ME FOR HER THERE IS NO
LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE A LONG TIME
LEFT TO LIVE.
I HAVE THE UTMOST FAITH IN HER
MOTHER AND IN HER FATHER.
THEY'RE PHE